my best friend tried to kill me with her
vehicle I was on life support for three
weeks I'm still trying to understand why
she did it she ruined my life and she
only got five years probation
[Music]
I took $100 from my dad's wallet he
found out and confronted me and my
brother I quickly put the money and my
brother's drawer my dad found and kicked
him out of the house that was a year ago
we haven't heard much since he won't
answer my calls or texts
my friend committed suicide last year
and I was the last person he tried
calling if I took the time and answered
he might still be here today
my little brother knocked his bowl of
ramen while watching TV
my father blamed it on me and after I
tried to explain myself he started
slapping me until my glasses fell on the
floor and broke my mother and my brother
did nothing later my mom said if people
ask how you brought your glasses tell
them it was because you fell on the
ground
I kept the fact that my dad was treating
on my mom with another woman I should be
a lot more mad at my dad but for some
reason I'm so guilt-ridden and anger at
myself for hurting the most important
person in my life I feel like whatever I
do I can't make it up to my mom it's a
lot more difficult of a decision I think
then people may realize maybe she sees
that and they divorced and it tears
apart your whole family or maybe she
doesn't believe it at all and then you
just become the bad guy first I was not
believed about my father getting
involved with a lady and speaking about
it helped cause a lot of drama and my
family but you shouldn't feel guilty
and you always have to remember that you
can't blame yourself for things that
other people are doing I was outed as a
lesbian by one of my closest friends two
teachers at my Catholic school I was
kicked out of that school in the middle
of my eighth grade year
so in college I met this person in
secret they told me that they were
discovering they were transgender and
they asked me not to tell anybody and I
broke that promise I got an email from
this person saying that I violated their
trust and that I should never speak to
them again and I really regret sharing
that information because it was not my
information to tell this person was
being vulnerable with me and I violated
the trust and I'm never gonna get that
back my mom passed away a few years ago
and everyday it feels like my memories
of her get blurrier I feel guilty and
mad at myself for forgetting her my dad
died from a stroke caused by
complications from long-standing blood
pressure problems we were fighting a lot
those days and were barely speaking when
he passed I fully believed that stress
of our relationship is what caused the
stroke and killed him that's really hard
to go through I don't think you should
be blaming yourself honestly time would
heal most things journaling has helped
talking to if you have your mother
figure in your life just being able to
really get your thoughts out so that
you're not choked up with all that guilt
inside just let it come out of you as a
child I was taking advantage of sexually
by multiple men in my family at age 15
when a school counselor heard about a
specific uncle touching me she called
the police and my mother what hurt the
most was when my mother was angry at me
instead I became disowned in my own home
for years it's especially hard when you
don't want to talk about it and you
don't want anybody to find out because
you have no idea what's gonna happen and
then you finally get the courage to say
something and it just ends up horrible
I'm sorry I understand
and it does help to talk about it having
people around you that support you and
that you can trust is very important
even talking to someone about things
like a therapist it helps even though it
seems like it won't at some point it's
going to get better I tried to kill
myself the same night after me and my
mother fought I went to my school to ask
for help
my mother was more mad at me for getting
help than the fact that I tried to end
my life sorry
just yesterday actually marked 10 years
that my mom left me and my dad and after
she left us when I started battling with
depression and anxiety and just like
abandonment issues and with that going
on I actually attempted suicide also
because I felt like if my mom didn't
want to stay with me then what is the
purpose of being here I feel for this
person because they wanted to end their
life after they fought with their mom I
hope their relationship with their
mother is good now and that they got the
help that they needed when I came out to
my parents as gay they told me to keep
my mouth shut and not tell anyone
because they could ruin the family name
they chose reputation over their own
child's happiness
so because of my background I'm Nigerian
I've been coming from a culture that
doesn't just not celebrate it but
discourages it can be especially
difficult the best thing is to find your
chosen family it's find people that will
support you and love you unconditionally
because you know you have to navigate
this crazy world with people on your
side it's unfortunate if it can't be
your bloodline but there are people you
should know that will support you
usually really got to pay attention to
who you bring into your life that type
of people they're around as well someone
who's your friend really someone who
looks out for you
[Music]